any other records with uh
anybody else on the album you could talk
about oh
i got uh i got
a record with john legend wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you got a
record with john legend
yeah yeah yeah
okay
it's actually my intro you got john
legend on the intro
yeah wait a minute
how the [ __ ] did that happen is this
who reached out to who uh i reached out
i reached out to his team
and uh he they just did they just did
yeah did he hit you in your pockets for
did he do it uh
i don't really know because i don't
handle that you're gonna find out when
you see the statement yeah
what do you gotta recoup for you
probably did but i think you know
another thing like that i don't really
think it's about the money it's like
easy
you got john legend on the intro to your
album yeah did you talk to him like like
meet him i ain't never even talk i ain't
know you talk to him like that
i ain't never even talked to him like
wow but
all right continue who else
we've established hers on the album
big sean's on the album um
obviously chris brown the two chains
yeah chris brown
uh obviously drake uh
[Music]
yeah that pretty i think that's pretty
much it uh i'm working on i'm working on
some
what's the name of the album yeah is
that out yeah uh no i
i didn't drop you here probably about
time and when is interview dropping when
you're gonna tell
probably next week like uh i ain't
enough
i wanna lost
i've been hitting at it for a long time
like just
within my statuses of posting stuff i
just been hitting that
him it's gonna be like investments part
whatever the [ __ ]
that's over that came to a conclusion
yeah that came to conclude
you